hans au cours du 20e siècle et début du
21e il ya extrêmement peu de victimes
même si un mort au maintien de l'ordre
et une catastrophe est tout à fait
déplorable on a vu des personnes
gravement blessées on a entendu aussi le
terme violences policières ce débat sur
les violences policières à ce qu'il a
toujours existé il a toujours existé la
première grande manifestation parisienne
du 6 février 34 on a même pu craindre la
disparition de la toute jeune garde
républicaine mobile dans la presse
s'était déchaînée sur ce qui était
réellement le noyau dur du dispositif de
maintien d'ordre à l'époque
[Musique]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on dit dans
les grandes entreprises multinationales
de saint gobain russie ukraine on a
beaucoup dit que bon
l'ouest et caïcos l'eau mais que l'est
et paul bert moi je suis convaincu à
titre personnel que il faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc et puis auxerre 2 il faut
réduire les émissions de carbone dans
les pays redevient sur partout partout
vous avez construit des vignes
décarbonés vos des usines où on est mais
rien du tout comme carbone dans l' usine
que ce soit nos émissions directes ou
alors des émissions liées à la
production d'électricité nous en avons
aujourd'hui dans dans le monde donc là
la conscience écologique aussi existe en
russie
[Musique]
alaigne deux ans après le soulèvement
social 15 millions de chiliens appelés
aux urnes pour choisir un successeur au
président sortant dont sebastian pinera
un scrutin sur fond de révision
constitutionnelle sept candidats en lice
dont deux favoris gabriel borique 30,50
candidat de la coalition de gauche et
josé antonio caste 55 ans à l'extrême
droite le pivot aussi pour des
législatives et des régionales
[Musique]
écarté lors du coup d'état militaire au
soudan le premier ministre abdallah doc
a retrouvé ce dimanche son poste après
un accord avec le général abdel fattah
al borhane une entente qui n'a pas
empêché un nouveau morts dans la
répression des manifestations anti
putsch en cours depuis à la prise de
pouvoir de la junte le 25 octobre
et puis ce vent de contestation qui
souffle en europe contre les
restrictions sanitaires après les
pays-bas l'autriche autour de la
belgique ils étaient 35 milles à
bruxelles selon la police des heurts
avec les forces de l'ordre qui ont
éclaté gaz lacrymogène pour contrer à
les jets de projectiles et canons à eau
pour disperser les contestataires au
moins deux policiers ont été blessés
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france et on commence
avec les élections à général au chili
deux ans après le soulèvement contre les
inégalités sociales et sur fond de
réforme de la constitution a les bureaux
de vote ils doivent fermer dans près de
deux heures au chili la balle sera 18
heures locales à 15 millions d'électeurs
appelés aux urnes pour choisir un
nouveau président et cela pour remplacer
sebastian pinera qui ne peut pas se
représenter après déjà deux mandats elle
ce dernier qui a échappé mardi à une
procédure de destitution
elle fait candidats sont en lice dont
deux favoris aux antipodes on les écoute
justement
l'essentiel pour nous est que beaucoup
de gens puissent aller voter et que
chacun puisse s'exprimer librement nous
tous ceux qui sont candidats avons déjà
parlé nous avons eu des mois pour faire
campagne aujourd'hui nous devons garder
nos opinions pour nous et attendre que
les gens votent
il s'agit de notre capacité à construire
un chili juste et digne avec des
retraites dignes pour les personnes
âgées une couverture sociale qui ne
discrimine pas notre capacité à
décentraliser a donné le pouvoir aux
territoires j'espère qu'il ya eu une
bonne participation aujourd'hui j'espère
que les gens comprennent que ce sont eux
les protagonistes de cette histoire
et on écouta les réactions à 2 quelques
citoyens chiliens se jouera de vàd
espérons le meilleur pour notre pays qui
est dans un très mauvais état espérons
le meilleur espérons-le avenir pour nos
enfants et notre famille espérons le
meilleur
je veux voir un changement dans
l'attitude des hommes politiques beaux
qu'ils soient plus honnête plus sincères
qu'ils tiennent leurs promesses et
qu'ils apportent de bonnes valeurs aux
personnes dans le besoin et au pays
j'espère que beaucoup de gens voteront
parce qu'il me semble qu'il s'agit d'une
élection très importante qui définira
l'avenir du chili à partir de maintenant
jusqu'à ma vieillesse et tout cela en
plus du processus constituant
la grande inconnue le taux de
participation qui s'annonce faible selon
franck gaudichaud et professeur en
histoire et civilisation d'amérique
latine à contemporaine à l'université
toulouse jean jaurès en écoute l'enjeu
est considérable on est effectivement
dans un moment clé de l'histoire
chilienne à deux ans de la grande
révolte qui avait eu en 2019 il ya une
assemblée constituante en tout cas une
nouvelle constitution qui en cours de
rédaction et le président sortant votre
reportage l'a bien dit est vraiment au
plus bas dans les sondages et une grande
crise de légitimité de la politique en
général des parties et donc pour les
chiliens il ya c'est un vote important
qui va permettre de savoir est ce que
coûtent les demandes sociales qui sont
exprimées depuis deux ans vont commencer
à avoir un début de réponse même si
aussi beaucoup de désillusions et
l'abstention il faudra la regarder de
près ce sera probablement assez forte la
pandémie la crise économique
actuellement au chili est très très
forte et ça aussi ça d impact sur le
vote et sur les formes de mobilisation
des jeunes aujourd'hui
autre élection importante cette fois au
venezuela les régionales et les
municipales un scrutin test pour le
président des colas maduro et l'ensemble
de l'opposition qui participe en ligne
de mire la présidentielle
2024 le président nicholas maduro a
autorisé la venue d'observateurs
internationaux il espère une levée des
sanctions qui pèsent lourdement sur
l'économie
du pays a de son côté l'opposition qui
avance en rangs dispersés cherche à se
lancer dans la course pour la
magistrature suprême surtout l'un de ses
leaders mark hurd au hacker s'est
autoproclamé président et on va écouter
quelques réactions des lecteurs sur
place
nous devons voter sinon il ne faut pas
qu'on se plaigne c'est le plus important
il ne sert à rien exprimé notre
mécontentement si on ne participe pas
aux élections
la venue des observateurs dans notre
pays n'est pas nécessaire nous avons ici
le conseil national électoral le plus
transparent du monde
le nicaragua a demandé officiellement à
sortir de l'organisation des états
américains le pays est en conflit avec
l'institution régionale depuis à la
réélection du président daniel ortega un
scrutin dont la légitimité contestée par
l'oat les précisions c'est avec un robin
tél
le fossé se creuse encore un peu plus
entre le nicaragua et l'organisation des
états américains
managua et en conflit ouvert avec le à
qu'elle juge contrôlée par washington et
accuse d'ingérence dans les affaires du
pays ce vendredi le gouvernement
nicaraguayen a officiellement demandé à
sortir de cette institution qui régit
les relations entre 35 états d'amérique
depuis 1948
le projet de loi constitue notre
décision indéfectible et déclaré de
dénoncer la charte de l'organisation des
états américains afin que ses effets
internationaux néfastes contre le
nicaragua cesse
le peuple et le gouvernement digne du
nicaragua renonce à faire partie de
cette organisation captive à washington
utilisé en faveur des intérêts
américains devenant un promoteur
d'ingérence et de désaccord au détriment
des peuples d'amérique latine et des
caraïbes
le nicaragua est sous le feu des
critiques de la communauté
internationale depuis la réélection de
daniel ortega le président a été
largement reconduit pour un quatrième
mandat après les élections du 7 novembre
dernier un résultat sans surprise
puisque le vote s'est déroulé sans
grandes figures d'opposition
trente neuf personnalités politiques ont
été arrêtés par les autorités depuis le
mois de juin parmi elles sept candidats
susceptibles de constituer une menace
pour le président sortant mardi dernier
joe biden a prononcé des sanctions à
l'encontre de daniel ortega et ses
proches collaborateurs
la répression et les abus du
gouvernement ortega et de ceux qui le
soutiennent impose aux états unis d'agir
j'ai pris la décision qu'il est dans
l'intérêt des états unis de restreindre
et suspendre l'entrée aux états unis des
membres du gouvernement du nicaragua
dirigé par le président daniel ortega y
compris son épouse et vice-présidente
rosario murillo et tous ceux qui sont
liés à des actes portant atteinte aux
institutions démocratiques les allmand
international du nicaragua pourrait
avoir de graves répercussions sur sa
situation économique le nicaragua est il
le plus pauvre d'amérique centrale est
fortement dépendant des investissements
étrangers de la coopération et des
financements par les organismes
internationaux de crédit
au soudan près d'un mois après la prise
de pouvoir des militaires le premier
ministre abdallah amdocs route rouge ses
fonctions à la demande de la communauté
internationale en accord a été signé ce
dimanche avec le général abdel fattah al
borhane à l'origine du putsch un
consensus qui n'arrive pas à les
opposants au pouce du 25 octobre depuis
ils se mobilisent malgré la répression
et un manifestant a été tué aujourd'hui
ce qui porte le bilan de la contestation
à 41 morts selon un comité de médecins
soudanais on voit cela va et de l'ego
gâche
en résidence surveillée depuis le coup
d'état du 25 octobre le premier ministre
déchu ray apparaît pour la cérémonie
officielle une cérémonie durant laquelle
l'accord avec le général abdel fattah al
bourhane a été signé avec ce document
les deux hommes s'engagent à rétablir
une période de transition démocratique
pour le pays
cet accord contribue nous l'espérons à
lever les blocages internes et externes
et à restaurer le processus de
transition vers une démocratie durable
nous vivons une crise depuis longtemps
grâce à dieu aujourd'hui avec la
signature de cet accord politique
nous avons réussi à instaurer une
véritable période de transition comme
nous l'avions prévu et comme le peuple
soudanais l'avait souhaité depuis le
soulèvement d'avril 2010 neuf
il ya plus de deux ans un partage du
pouvoir entre civils et militaires
étaient instaurées après le renversement
de l'ancien président omar el béchir une
transition censée mener le pays vers des
élections libres en 2023 conditions
posées par la communauté internationale
pour soutenir à nouveau le soudan
l'accord signé ce dimanche prévoit aussi
la libération des ministres et
dirigeants civils arrêtés lors du putsch
le document donne également pour mission
au chef de gouvernement de former un
nouveau cabinet de technocrates
mais cet accord n'a pas convaincu les
manifestants anti coup d'état ils
étaient à nouveau dans la rue dans
plusieurs villes du pays pour exiger le
départ des militaires
[Musique]
actuellement amdocs n'est plus acceptée
dans les rues si vous entendez les
champs maintenant ils se sont tous
transformés en appel contre lui en
faisant ce qu'il a fait il a trahi la
rue il a trahi tous les accords que nous
avions avec lui pour un gouvernement
civil et une transition vers un régime
civil
[Musique]
l'accord qui a été annoncé il y à
quelques heures ne représente pas du
tout le peuple soudanais
ni le sang innocent qui a été versé sur
cette terre depuis 1989
des protestataires qui n'oublie pas la
répression des manifestations anti coup
d'état répression qui a fait plus de 40
morts selon un syndicat de médecins sous
d'année la police assure n'avoir jamais
ouvert le feu elle ne recense
officiellement qu'un mort et 30 blessés
parmi les protestataires
une mobilisation contre le putsch
déterminante selon marc lavergne
directeur de recherche au cnrs
spécialiste du soudan et de la corne de
l'afrique on écoute
la société civile soudanaise est tout à
fait impressionnant dans sa
détermination dans son sens du sacrifice
en particulier la jeunesse cette
mobilisation elle elle tranche avec le
sort de beaucoup de printemps arabe qui
ont été écrasés par l'armée je crois
qu'il ya vraiment au soudan un peuple
contre une armée une armée qui s'est
toujours battu contre le peuple
soudanais jamais contre les puissances
étrangères donc il ya des situations
extrêmement instable sur quoi que les
militaires en sous-estimer la
détermination des soudanais qui encore
une fois ont une expérience démocratique
ancien c'est ça qui est différent de
beaucoup de pays de la région c'est que
les soudanais sont attachés à leur
liberté à la démocratie
je crois que cette mobilisation on a
retiré à parlerai elle sur le ces jeunes
manifestants je ne pense pas qu'ils vont
laisser tomber et on en vient à ce vent
de contestation contre les mesures de
restrictions sanitaires qui souffle en
europe les pays bas l'autriche est
maintenant à la belgique 35 mille
manifestants à bruxelles ce dimanche et
des heures vous le voyez avec les forces
de l'ordre qui ont fait usage de gaz
lacrymogènes et de canons à eau elle les
policiers ont été visés par des jets de
projectiles mercredi dernier le
gouvernement belge a annoncé le retour
du masque obligatoire dans les
transports en commun et les lieux de
culture pour faire face à la hausse des
cas de coded on va en parler tout de
suite avec notre invité yves van laethem
et les infectiologues au chu
saint-pierre et porte-parole
interfédérale de la lutte contre le coc
vite 19
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france en tant que
infectiologues quel regard vous portez
d'abord sur les manifestations du jour à
bruxelles
et je pense qu'ils sont effectivement
regretter avec des sons témoins et que
la population un peu partout dans le
monde en europe de l'ouest comme
ailleurs on a un petit peu marre
effectivement de cette situation qui
dure qui dure depuis un an et demi et
que ne comprend plus bien la finalité
des mesures qui sont encore nécessaires
et malheureusement ces mesures en plus
de la vaccination sont encore
nécessaires selon vous les mesures
décidées par les autorités ce qu'elles
sont bonnes pour faire face à la
recrudescence de l'épidémie le port du
masque est généralisée en intérieur le
télétravail les jauges pour les
événements
alors effectivement les autorités sont
basés sur le rapport de ce qu'on appelle
j'aime c'est un comité
essayé avec des mesures de relativement
simple bien connu le juguler cette
quatrième vague que nous connaissons est
d'éviter que l'on doive recourir comme
aux pays-bas un délai aux douanes
partiel comme en autriche à vélo en plus
complet avec un confinement on espère
vraiment dans les semaines qui viennent
parvenir à écrêter cette augmentation
avec c'est un peu monsieur bien sûr si
elles sont appliquées et en haut niveau
de la vaccination est ce qu'on en est en
belgique aujourd'hui
autour de la vaccination des taux sont
extrêmement bon vous semble et 6e
européen avec 76% la population totale
vacciner 86 conscience si on prend les
plus de 18 ans et les fronts des
populations fragiles et comme les plus
de 65 ans sont vaccinés à 90 2% ce qui
se passe c'est que une partie des
groupes n'est pas vacciner la population
est vaccinée de manière hétérogène à
bruxelles entre autres et en wallonie et
que d'autre part une partie des
personnes ont besoin d'une troisième
dose et non pour apprêter recevoir c'est
le troisième dose les personnes âgées de
plus de 65 ans alors on voit ce vent de
contestation un peu partout en europe
qui commence assez généralisé il y à une
rengaine de l'épidémie aujourd'hui
quelles sont vos prévisions
je pense que c'est vague avec des
mesures qui sont prises dans toute
l'europe de l'ouest s'éteindre dans les
semaines qui viennent les mesures sont
différents mais je pense qu'il ne
signait un peu ce même près on aura la
même lame extinction et j'espère
effectivement pour la mi-décembre
l'europe de l'ouest soit retrouvé un
climat épidémiologique plus plus calme
si pas parfait bien sûr alors c'est vrai
qu'avec la pensée de la couverture
vaccinale au niveau européen on se dit
aussi que les cas graves sont nombreux
c'est une réalité
mais ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter sur la
situation des hôpitaux
au niveau des hôpitaux le problème c'est
qu'ils ne sont plus dans le même état
qui un an un an et demi tous les pays
connaissent là une défection du
personnel hospitalier qui est usée qui
est fatigué qui est déprimé la plupart
des hôpitaux auront 15 à 30 los andes le
personnel indisponible 6 qui condamne un
certain nombre de vies et le grand du
problème est plus dans cette diminution
de la réelle capacité des hôpitaux que
dans leurs charges nous avons 600
tranquille de soins intensifs occupés
sur les deux milieux lits de soins
intensifs c'est la moitié de ce qu'on
avait dans les vagues précédentes mais
le personnel a duré ce livre et qu'est
ce que les autorités belges en craignent
le plus
clairement c'est de ne pas pouvoir
suivre dans les soins n'ont que vite
puisque le sommes en pleine saison
hivernale on a tous des infections
pulmonaires classique on a le retard à
rattraper sur les interventions
chirurgicales haguenau et autres bugs et
il est clair que c'est cette partie là
des choses les soins adéquats pour les
autres pathologies qui attire le plus
attention et à votre avis est-ce que
c'est leur tour des mesures de
restriction sont nécessaires aujourd'hui
pour faire face à cette nouvelle vague
épidémique en europe je pense qu'avec
les vaccins on a trop vite cru que la
vaccin seuls allait suffire beaucoup
d'études montrent maintenant que pendant
plusieurs mois encore après les bonnes
campagnes de vaccination il faut
l'accompagner des mesures classiques de
distance iman de masques de bonne
aération parce qu'il reste des postes
population pas suffisamment couvertes et
que si on abolit ce genre de mesure et
bien le co vite en profite pour renvoyer
le terrain en question merci à beaucoup
avoue yves leterme je rappelle que vous
êtes infectiologues fut saint pierre et
porte-parole interfédérale de la lutte
contre le coc vide 19
et puis ce week end mouvementé en
guadeloupe après l'interpellation de 38
manifestants dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche depuis une semaine les
guadeloupéens font face à un mouvement
social d'ampleur cela fait suite à
l'appel d'un collectif d'organisations
syndicales pour lutter contre
l'instauration du passé ni terre et
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants
donc ça fait plusieurs jours que lille
et perturbés par des blocages et des
violences des pillages des incendies les
forces de l'ordre sont même visés par
des tirs d'armes à feu une situation je
cite absolument intolérable et
inacceptable selon le porte-parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent est le
ministre de l'intérieur lui gérald
darmanin il a annoncé l'envoi sur l'île
d'une cinquantaine de membres des forces
d'élite du gign et du raid à une
situation inédite l'union générale des
travailleurs est l'un des syndicats
impliqués dans ce mouvement de
contestation il appelle à poursuivre la
mobilisation écouter la secrétaire
général mike byrd to move
début c'est vrai qu'ils avaient la
contestation contre l'obligation
vaccinale écoute pas sanitaire mais à
travers cette mobilisation et b
l'ensemble des jeunes de guadeloupe et
la population à continuer a dit aucun en
guadeloupe ya pas que ça ça a été la
goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase
mais il faut savoir qu'on avait mis en
place un accord en 2009 l'accord bino et
l'accord du 4 mars qui normalement est
essentiel régler tous les problèmes en
guadeloupe d'autres sociale économique
et politique mais rien n'a été respectée
donc aujourd'hui la situation a empiré
la situation empirer et cela c'est
normal que finalement on aboutit à cette
situation de révolte les gens n'en
peuvent plus les gens sont en colère et
les gens ne peuvent plus long
aujourd'hui il est urgent et les temps
de régler les problèmes de s'asseoir et
de régler les problèmes peut permettre
aux guadeloupéens de vivre dans leur
pays et c'est l'un des pays de l'union
européenne avec le plus faible taux de
vaccination la bulgare nice dans ce
contexte sanitaire délicat que le second
tour de la présidentielle
le tout à l'heure romaine radeff a été
reconduit à la tête du pays il a
recueilli entre 63 et 65 % des suffrages
selon des estimations de sorties des
urnes de trois instituts de sondage et
fait figure d'icône de la lutte
anti-corruption ce scrutin a lieu une
semaine après la victoire surprise aux
législatives d'un parti novice en
politique continue on le change
d'enfants
cette nouvelle étape maintenant dans la
crise diplomatique entre la chine et la
lituanie pékin décide de réduire ses
relations avec le pays balte après que
ce dernier a accepté d'accueillir
l'ambassade de taïwan dans sa capitale
une position jugée partiale par la chine
opposés depuis des décennies à
l'autonomie de l'île
rupture diplomatique consommé entre la
chine et la lituanie la décision vient
du gouvernement chinois qui entend bien
défendre ses intérêts à l'international
le gouvernement chinois a dû abaisser
les relations diplomatiques entre les
deux pays afin de sauvegarder sa
souveraineté et les normes fondamentales
des relations internationales en cause
l'accueil par la lituanie jeudi dernier
d'une représentation diplomatique
taïwanaise une première en europe depuis
18 ans pour pékin c'est une provocation
supplémentaire
le gouvernement lituanien doit assumer
toutes les conséquences qui en découlent
ces actions ont créer un mauvais
précédent sur la scène internationale un
sujet sensible pour la chine qui
considère taïwan comme une de ses
provinces une idée à laquelle s'oppose
le gouvernement taïwanais en quête
d'indépendance depuis la guerre civile
de 1949
civile nuss dit regretter la décision de
la chine elle affirme vouloir avant tout
privilégier ses intérêts économiques
nous pensons que les liens économiques
avec les états démocratiques sont plus
stables et durables ils sont fondés sur
l'état de droit donc ils répondent mieux
aux intérêts de la lituanie cet été
l'ouverture de l'ambassade taiwanaises à
vilnius avait déjà déclenché la colère
de pékin qui avait rappelé son
ambassadeur tout en exigeant de la
lituanie qu elle rapatrie ses propres
diplomates
hymus n'en est pas à son premier coup
d'essai puisque en 2021 le gouvernement
lituanien s'était déjà retiré d'une
plate forme économique regroupant chine
et pays européens tout en appelant son
peuple à boycotter les smartphones
chinois reste à voir si cette première
crise déclaré suscitera d'autres
vocations à un moment où les relations
internationales se crispe autour du
conflit sino taïwan et
la coupe du monde au qatar ce sera dans
un an alors que le pays est dans la
dernière ligne droite il est toujours
aussi critiqué par de nombreuses ong
pour les violations de droits humains
doit s'en défend et trouve injuste la
manière dont elle est traitée on voit
cela avec guy marrot vie et katia clic
la coupe du monde de football 2022 une
grand messe sportive brassant des
milliards d'euros est accueilli dans
l'un des bastions mondiaux de l'
esclavage moderne le qatar c'est ce que
dénonce amnesty international dans un
rapport publié il ya quelques jours
l'eau njai note bien une amélioration
dans la législation relative aux droits
humains mais en pratique le qatar est
encore loin de tenir ses engagements en
terme de respect du droit des
travailleurs immigrés au nombre de 2
millions dans le pays l'autosatisfaction
manifeste des autorités exposé des
milliers de personnes à risques
persistants d'exploitation par des
employeurs peu scrupuleux dans des
situations où beaucoup d'entre elles ne
sont pas en mesure de changer d'emploi
et sont victimes de pratiques
s'apparentant à un vol de salaire en
cause la kafala cette pratique de
parrainage qui a cours dans les pays du
golfe persique
tout étranger qui souhaite travailler au
qatar doit passer par les fourches
caudines d'un cas fils un sponsor local
qui a tout pouvoir sur l'employé et a
notamment pour habitude de lui
confisquer son passeport avec les
dérives que l'on imagine malgré les
réformes adoptées par doha certains
éléments problématiques du système de
kafala reste en place cela inclut la
possibilité pour des employeurs abusifs
de s'opposer à ce que les travailleurs
migrants change de travail et de
contrôler leur statut juridique d'autres
dérives inclut le non versement de
salaires et le refus d'octroyer certains
avantages afin qu'il soit plus difficile
pour les travailleurs et travailleuses
de quitter leur emploi les migrants
immigrantes continue à dépendre de leurs
employeur pour entrer au qatar et y
rester ce qui donne lieu à des tactiques
auquel les employeurs abusifs recours
afin de contrôler leur main d'oeuvre
privés de leurs droits un grand nombre
de travailleurs immigrés majoritairement
issus d'asie travail en conséquence dans
les pires conditions imaginables
et cela vaut pour les forçats des
chantiers de la coupe du monde selon
l'organisation internationale du travail
cinquante travailleurs immigrés sont
décédées au qatar l'an dernier et un
demi millier d'autres ont été grièvement
blessés majoritairement dans le secteur
de la construction selon une enquête du
guardian paru en février dernier plus de
6500 travailleurs indiens népal et au
bangladesh ont trouvé la mort depuis
2010 au qatar un chiffre qui pourrait
être sous-évalué les décès sont pour la
plupart survenus sur les nombreux
chantiers des routes autoroutes
aéroports hôtels et bien sûr des stades
le tout lié à l'organisation du mondial
les résultats révèle l'incapacité du
qatar a protégé sa main-d'oeuvre
migrante forte de deux millions de
personnes ou même à enquêter sur les
causes du taux apparemment élevé de
décès parmi ces travailleurs pour la
plupart jeunes face à ce drame humain
certaines voix du monde du foot se sont
élevées surtout en provenance des pays
nordiques comme le danemark seule équipe
scandinave qualifier au mondial la
fédération danoise a prévu de remplacer
sur le maillot des joueurs les habituels
logos des sponsors par des messages sur
les droits de l'homme cela dit pour le
moment rien ne compromet réellement la
tenue du mondial au qatar pas plus que
n'en avait été bouleversée celle de 1978
organisée par la junte argentine du
général videla alors au pouvoir pour son
plus grand bénéfice mais cette fois au
delà du contexte politique c'est
l'organisation même de l'épreuve qui est
sujette à caution son attribution fait
toujours l'objet d'une enquête pour
corruption active et passive recel et
blanchiment on entend souvent que le
sport n'a rien à voir avec la politique
rarement une phrase n'a été aussi
impropre et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve dans trentaine de minutes
rester avec nous sur arte france à tout
à l'heure
[Musique]
pourquoi la guinée reste engluée dans
cette spirale de coups d'état depuis
l'indépendance jusqu'à présent on était
dans le même cycle politique un état
répressif des élites porté vers la
corruption vers les détournements de
deniers publics
une volonté de confisquer les attributs
de l'ensemble de la souveraineté c'est
laden de la classe politique qui a pris
la place du colon jusqu'à présent le
coup d'état du 5 septembre n'a pas
surpris est-ce que c'était prévisible
pour vous également tu était tout à fait
prévisible
puis deux années même avec monsieur
alpha condé les deux pays étaient dans
une crise profonde à la fin de son
second mandat il a cherché par tous les
moyens y compris de moyens tout à fait
inadmissible à se maintenir au pouvoir
[Musique]
le cas